مع رامز وصحه الفنان محمد فؤاد شاغله
الاخبار والمنصات واليوم في تطور جديد
بيزيد القلق حولها من كم يوم ان عرضت حلقه
من برنامج مقالب رامز وكان الضيف محمد
فؤاد وفي اول الحلقه قال انه عامل تكميم
معده من 15 يوم لكن بعدها رامز كمل المقلب
وكان مقلب الغساله وكان في يعني خلينا
نقول هز وخذ خضراء في الاخر شفناك محمد
فؤاد ماسك جرح وفي دم في يده وبعد عرض
المقلب طلع الدكتور
واتهم رامز وطاقم البرنامج بارتكاب جريمه
وقال انه كان في خطوره حقيقيه على حياه
محمد فؤاد ويعني هاجم البرنامج باشد
العبارات لكن ارجع حول البوست لخص بدل ما
هو عام وقال انه محمد فؤاد كلمه وقال له
انه كويس وخلاص الجديد اليوم انباء
متداوله في وسائل اعلام مصريه بتقول انه
محمد فؤاد تعرض لاصابه في العمود الفقري
من بعد مشاركته باحد البرامج الرمضانيه
ونروح يسافر على المانيا في الشهر علشان
يتعالج ومع انه ما تم ذكر اسم البرنامج
لكن الناس كلها قالت انه المقصود هو
مشاركته في حلقه رامز نيفر اند محمد فؤاد
للان ما في نفي او تاكيد منه للاخبار لكن
متداول كلام على المنصات انه اطمن الناس
عليه وقال انه صحته جيده وما اشبو شيء
يعني الاموره تمام رغم الكلام المتداول
هذا عن محمد فؤاد وتاكيده انه تمام لكن في
ناس لسه قلقانه وبتستشهد بفيديو نشره
الفنان والنقيب مصطفى كامل واللي كمان كان
هو ضيف في برنامج رامز والناس بتقول انه
كلام محمد فؤاد في الفيديو دليل انه صحته
مو تمام
دي انا وانت بعد بعد ما هزرنا في مقلب
ثقيل
بلاوي كل سنه وانت طيب